so wait are there any animals that
you're afraid of
yeah I have actually a phobia oh like
I'm always called to be the collector of
the animals like there's a spider
there's a tarantula okay come down I
picked them up I bring them outside yeah
me too butt snakes I don't care if it's
a Scorpio I'm not afraid but snakes I
have a phobia yeah so tell me yeah
thank you
because because
I specifically remember as a child going
first of all how many milk ads do I need
to read and drink milk to get to look
like that you know like those ads when
you're a kid um and secondly like how
did you handle that that's a cute that's
a python I can't think because I'm still
going around the fact that you said as a
kid
yeah but that's because we look the same
age because you found the Fountain of
Youth
well you know I had to Go On trance
because if I if I was not on trance if
you look at my eyes I look a little
no one knows looking at your eyes
that's the thing if you really study my
eyes if you really you have to focus on
that yes um yeah I mean this was I
remember this as a kid I mean even
Britney Spears ended up doing that thing
with the python thing yeah I was just
that should be culture thing yeah but
they didn't have to Go On trance like me
and the thing is that you cannot did you
tell them that you like did you just
tell him that you were terrified of
snakes yeah oh and you just yeah oh yeah
Robert Rodriguez said well Madonna wants
your part if you cannot dance with the
snake I called Madonna and I'm like
Madonna doesn't want my little part okay
so don't try to they're trying to
manipulate yes but I I did I was proud
to because when you were acting you have
to become someone else did that help
that's yes absolutely that's how you do
everything but it's it was I was very
proud that I was freed of my phobia I
didn't have to give her my phobia she
got to be and and also
um you girls are gonna like this I
studied a lot about the meaning of a
snake and it represents your inner power
so my when I was going on trance it was
about dancing with my inner power like
having a dance with my inner power and I
I gotta say girls when you are sad yeah
or you feel like you have no strength
close the door
put some music and dance like nobody's
watching until you get things
but it does it makes me feel so good to
dance I love movies yeah and when I
close my eyes I picture I look like you
ha
[Music]
[Applause]
UNT I'm going
[Music]